Jay Leno is currently walking through I
mean he has a Palace full of I want to
go to jail I wish I was in quarantine
with Jay Leno right now anyway he's
gonna take us on a tour of his garage so
here we go wait is this your garage at
your house is that real oh yeah this is
no it's not really that's all illusion
yes yes no I'm like are you in a studio
that's legit it's not like a restaurant
buying you it looks like a little you
should have a diner cuz it's all cute
for the cars let's call the kitchen I
know you should have Jay Leno's diner
teach of the whole I have never felt
more like pretty woman you know and the
story don't belong and you don't you
know you're trying to buy something like
you know I'm here no I like when she
does a place where she doesn't belong
all right where are you at right now Jay
well we're just crossing into another
building I want to show you I like cars
set up sometimes you buy the story as
much as you buy the car like the cars
I'm standing in front of now these are
both Hudson Hornets this is a 1953 is
1951 and I bought this one first and I
restored it and then one day I got a
call from a 94 year old woman and she
said I miss land really like cars my
husband and I bought a brand-new 51
Hudson Hornet 51 and we drove from New
Jersey with my family for a new life in
California he died 96 this is back
before said you uh you mentioned buying
the car and I said I already have a
Hudson Hawk she goes well it's a 100 car
you just come looking at it alright so I
Drive it out there 94 years old mo
hearing or no glasses
looks like she's six
so she showed me the car and got four
flat tires and been sitting for 20 years
but he died back in 96 isn't $2 for she
doesn't we give me $5,000
I said well alright okay so I bought it
I felt sorry that brought it back to my
garage took about two years to restore
it and I think see if she's still alive
right now remember here hello shame on
all of us
now she's 96 and I said listen I
finished the car it looks my new you
want to go she goes kinky kids come I go
well sure we'll her kids are 74 and 72
so we're driving on she's telling me
stories about you know coming across
route 66 back in the fifties and one was
like meanwhile two kids in the back and
I was really just a wonderful but she
lived to be 100 which she had such fun
with the two kids and you know that's
what makes this fun especially this is
not really a special car until you know
the story is the only car they had and
the 72 year old to certain floors only
told me that when they were teenagers
they were so embarrassed that the
parents car was 16 years old that they
have the dad drop him off like three
blocks from the school and then they
would walk to school so other kids would
see they did the admirable 1951 classic
but back then that was a whole different
story so that's so that's that's a car
with a pretty good story well um can we
see another car you have in there this
is my 55 Buick Roadmaster
well I came to Los Angeles newsstand I
bought a copy of the penny saver that's
like one
you know people have things for sale and
I was looking for a car but la in a car
before you need a place to live if you
can't get to the place to live unless
you have a cop so I saw this advertised
attorney 50 bucks and I bought it and
I've had it to 1972 I met my wife in
this car and we dated in this car I took
this got on my first Tonight Show I
think it's my last a night job I'll tell
you a story my wife hates my wife hates
this story but it's kind of funny
because we had our first encounter in
this encounter on our 25th wedding
anniversary let's try and recreate that
so we both got the car every drove to
where we had our encounter but now it's
a housing development so I'm like okay I
think it's right with that houses okay
pull up on the street okay and the house
is like right there so you're not as
agile at 25 with you are me my hair and
the horn I see the porch light come on
the guy comes running out what's going
on out here but we had a lot of laughs
it's pretty funny that's pretty much how
marriage goes though right the second
one are different exactly I'm just
kidding no that's awesome I think you
have found the love of your life and you
can make out in the car I have made out
with my man in the car as well that's a
really cool car a car like this this is
such a big car you don't even have a
radio you can just bring in live acts
play right there with you yeah
REO we actually have a clip of me and my
driving skills with mr. Leno on his show
Jay Leno's Garage which you can watch on
CNBC you'll check out this clip right
here oh my god I want to know it
underground tunnel things it's an actual
goldmine it's been here for over a
hundred years
really you probably shouldn't go in oh
we should go in why a little pretty
sturdy safe this is sturdy oh my god
it's pretty that guy in here no I know
it's echoey but don't sing in a mind
you're not supposed to
all right thank you so much J I always
love talking to you everybody yes
everybody go watch Jay Leno's Garage
Wednesday's on CNBC especially my
episode which airs June 24th I'm an
expert drivers on saying subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going